stéphanie grammond luc ferrandez
christian dufour bonsoir
mr j'accueille christian dufour
j'accueille crise en dessous oui
j'accueille qu'elle sort du four depuis
longtemps mais j'accueille luc ferrandez
ce panel vous l'avez vu dans d'autres
panels
merci d'être là le
monsieur legault on a parlé de la
violence en début d'émission il à dire
il y allait avoir des des annonces
contre les gangs de rue on verra mais il
a aussi beaucoup parlé de transports
avec la mairesse de raismes de l'instant
trouvé là le rem de l'est s'il veut
apaiser ceux qui ont des craintes on
écoute on revient
on a été très clair avec charlie monde
président de la caisse on veut que la
caisse travaille avec la ville de
montréal travail que le gouvernement du
québec donc ils y ont présenté un projet
ce projet ce projet là doit être bonifié
moi je vous dis ouah à ceux entre autres
qui ont manifesté de je vous ai entendu
je comprends que des améliorations à
apporter au projet de la caisse on veut
travailler avec la ville de montréal
avec le gouvernement du québec
parce qu'il ya un tournant lors ou en
tout cas il ya une proue ses prises de
positions stéphanie je commençais avec
vous en plus de femmes monsieur legault
audio je vais je veux serrer un peu la
vis aux prêts de la caisse je veux que
soient plus ouverts aux commentaires
comment tu
sais c'est en tout cas c'est très
agréable d'entendre le premier ministre
dire qu'il le 2 mai quoique qu'il a
entendu les critiques parce que c'est
vrai qu'il y en a beaucoup
les gens se préoccupent on voit déjà
avec la première phase a donnée dans
certains quartiers où j'étais vraiment à
une intégration et pourra entendre dans
les quartiers résidentiels c'est certain
que les gens n'enlèvent boisseau et en
raison de d'être préoccupés même chose
pour le centre ville la mairesse l'avait
dit aussi qu'elle était préoccupée mon
sens fait pas qu'il y avait une
véritable écoute et puis dans la
première phase dure ma la caisse de
dépôt on a vu qu ils ont ils ont passé
pas mal en bottes doseur un peu partout
donc hélas et c'est bien d'entendre dans
la bouche du premier ministre parce que
oui il faut que ça s'intègre dans le
paysage urbain c'est pas nécessairement
un
tracé à érié en béton qui est cadre dans
lorsqu'on a envie d'avoir aujourd'hui en
2021 dans un pays comme montréal il ya
plein d'autres villes comme paris et qui
ont plutôt décidé d'enfouir
les nouvelles stations de métro qu'ils
ont construites donc pourquoi pas ici je
dis faut qu'on se penche là-dessus mais
dans quelle mesure luc et christian vous
avez noté un vraiment un changement de
cap ou bien on est à la marge les y aura
peut-être des détails un peu
modifié lui qu il fait preuve de bonne
de bonnes intentions mais est ce qu'il
va être capable de livrer ses beautés en
solo il ya des éléments importants
d'abord les projets réussis sont des
projets qui sont intégrés on conçoit a
en même temps la kz donc le projet
lui-même aérien mais aussi ce qui
l'entouré où caisse ou home et le
résidentiel à quelle distance etc et là
on a un axe et cdpq et frob fonctionne
en faisant juste lax lyon pas un mandat
de faire de la planification du
territoire la deuxième chose c'est qu'on
a un projet très particulier à montréal
à cause de la neige il va être surmontés
de fils c'est à dire que y'a des poteaux
sur la sur le tablier de béton il ya des
poteaux et sur ses poteaux l'a donc des
caténaires c'est très différent de tous
les projets qui nous ont montré en photo
j'aurais aimé que pour entraîner taissy
veulent préparer progression est ce que
vous vous êtes là il y aura plein de
vieux fel comme les tramways à l'époque
un poteau là oui oui il va ya voir sa
valeur dans notre son harem de l'estrie
ah non c'est moi qui sont venus écouter
phobique tous les photos que cdpq efron
ou mon cd photos sans poteaux alors
montrez nous la vraie chose puis on va
parler on va pouvoir accueillir plus des
mains en même temps on a fait beaucoup
de panels sur piste un gros projet drame
de l'est c'est combien s'est rendu à ces
familles c'est une oeuvre 10 milliards
ouais environ 10 milliards précédemment
voir ce que c'est que ça un bon coup
c'est quoi le rapport coûts bénéfices
dans tout ça mais parce que christian ce
que j'allais dire c'est qu'en même temps
il ya des gens qui étaient contents
parce que pour une fois les projets
avancent
c'est toujours ça en fait le dilemme bon
on peut se mettre à consulter consulter
consultés on sait qu'aujourd'hui c'est
du très difficile de mener à terme des
deux gros projets parce que toujours des
nouveaux problèmes des objections qui
arrivent mais en même temps il faut
arriver ces projets là avec le milieu
local j'écoutais stéphanie puis lui je
pense aux trois ans et demi à québec je
me suis enfant leur haine
sur le voit déjà problème avec ce méga
projet à québec donc l'homme pour
l'instant ce sont des belles paroles ou
quand même être réaliste mais c'est une
bonne chose que le ton change parce
qu'on avait l'impression que le projet
était piloté par des espions qui étaient
sympas québec où la caisse de dépôt puis
l'arrimage avec le meur le milieu
montréalais était vraiment insuffisante
et entre autres avec la ville donc c'est
une bonne nouvelle que ce changement de
ton loc mais il faut alors attendre
quand même les gestes les actions parce
que stéphanie on avait noté que lors du
discours inaugural de monsieur legault
le mot montréal n'avait pas été prononcé
on sent de manière plus générale que là
elle fait partie elle a toujours fait
partie de l'équation mais la ville
davantage sera une préoccupation
politique mais espère on veut parce que
c'est vrai que dans le discours
d'ouverture
il y avait il y avait un grand absent et
c'était c'est la ville de montréal bus
et cars mais une c'est un parfum de
c'est la locomotive du québec on peut
pas faire abstraction ce et c'est vrai
que lacan qui s'est passé poste c'est
pas montréal qui font leurs plus grands
gains politiques mais il faut quand même
rebâtir des ponts je pense que la
mairesse de montréal valérie plan a été
rayée vu aussi ce devoir là de tendre la
main
et de demander hier au premier ministre
est bon
est-ce qu'on peut travailler ensemble
mais puis le premier ministre avantage
aussi à aller dans ce sens-là par celui
ayant voix pour c'est dans l'intérêt de
toute la province au complet
petite chose il faut pas oublier que
madame plante vient d'être réélu avec
une majorité substantielle donc elle la
nouvelle légitimité politique par
rapport à françois legault jusqu'à
présent on avait l'impression que dans
le junior par rapport à mort sur le coup
je flat contexte politique que quand
même changé pour la paix bien qu est ce
que vous voyez une différence ou c'est
ce que vous voyez une différence dans la
main dans le jeu politique là qui
commence oui tout à fait
d'abord parce que elle même été élu avec
une marge époustouflante le d'une part
d'autre part parce que l'état contre
elles et eux au centre de deux autres
villes laval et longueuil qui ont des
préoccupations semblables et vont
pouvoir se se lit pour aller chercher
ddp gains pour montréal et sa région ont
aussi eu du logement très important dans
le domaine de la sécurité dans le
domaine des transports longuet us il ya
un énorme projet de est-ce que ça va
être rien mais sans doute à m mais du
moins à restructurer dont on a des
projets semblables ils vont pouvoir se
donner la main et exiger faire une sorte
de front commun avec 20 points face à
québec comme c'était dans une opposition
mais je comprends très bien
avez vous vu si vous étiez en début
d'émission avec nous a vu ces images de
papillons de contes pour enfants on veut
créer des lieux de vaccination mais
vraiment très différent vous les voyez
des papillons par ci des petits
personnages par là on va monter la
température pour pas qu'il fasse froid
du tout il ya des télévisions est ce que
c'est ce qu'il fallait faire c'est fanny
d'après vous pour attirer les enfants
mais les parents surtout dans ces
centres de vaccination qui vont ouvrir
incessamment
je pense que c'est sûrement très bien
mais il ya du travail à faire parce que
y'a seulement 60 % des parents et qu'ils
ont l'intention de faire vacciner leurs
petits ça c'est quand même peu je pense
qu'il faut marteler un message clair il
faut répéter le comité consultatif
national le vendredi
au fait ça rapport indique que oui il
faut faire vacciner les enfants ce
souhaitable parce qu'il ya encore des
gens qui se demandent et puis qui se
questionnaient probablement à juste
titre à savoir est ce que ça vaut la
peine puisque les enfants sont patents
malade mais oui il y en a qui peuvent
l'être beaucoup on a vu des reportages
là sur un jeune qui s'est retrouvé à
l'hôpital après que son professeur
d'arts plastiques le dans le dans le
quartier rosemont avait infecté à peu
près toute l'école donc lieu des enfants
qui sont très malades il ya des écoles
qui ferment à cause de ça donc ce sont
des dommages collatéraux si on veut ah
oui il faut il faut que le message passe
il faut qu'on prenne tous les moyens y
compris dans les quartiers moins
favorisés parce qu'on sait qu'il ya une
école dans la dans la dans les succès de
la vaccination et c'est triste de voir
que dans les quartiers moins favorisés
les gens sont moins vacciner donc il
faut faire attention aux fausses voilà
ce n'est pas trop en faire que que
d'élaborer c'est ça les plus âgés il
faut il faut tenter le tout pour le tout
absolument très bien nuque moi je trouve
ça mignon comme tous les enfants vont
être heureux c'est super mais c'est pas
ça qui va prouver que les parents
avaient envoyé la wii dans un train de
la vaccination le 60% de parents qui ont
décidé déjà d'envoyer des enfants se
faire vacciner il correspond à peu près
au pourcentage d'adultes qui avait dit
qu'il se fait vacciner avant la campagne
de vaccination et puis ce pourcentage là
où beaucoup augmenté quand les gens ont
vu que il n'y avait pas d'effet
secondaire qui jure que ça se passait
bien je pense que c'est aussi ce qui va
se passer avec la vaccination des
enfants christian
je trouve ça extrêmement délicat la
vaccination des enfants
c'est comme l'autre extrême savez on a
parlé longtemps tu fait qu'il y avait
des travailleurs de la santé qui
refusait d'être vacciné même s'il avait
le droit de refuser c'était difficile à
comprendre moi ça se fait qu'il refuse
d'être sexy mais moi je comprends très
bien les licences de beaucoup de parents
de voir leurs enfants vaccinés on
comprend ce sont des enfants et puis les
enfants n'a personne pas les enfants
quand même sont sous la responsabilité
des parents donc pour faire très
attention à la dedans il faut être très
humain il faut aussi réaliser qu'on est
beaucoup dans une idéologie s'interroger
soutint mais je pense que c'est plus en
plus comme moi ça me désole le risque
zéro le demi-centre plus personne ne
conteste jamais rien bon enfin de celui
qu'il faut faire vacciner des enfants
mais il faut faire vraiment très très
très attention moment il ya une
idéologie l'offre cash très pop comment
ça me déprime et beaucoup et on se
concentre sur son année on est de
montrer notre passion aux réflexions
qu'on avait eu juste un an un an et demi
on est à des années lumières comme une
espèce des toasts sanitaire qui s'est
installée et puis il faut s'inscrire
parce que demain ça sera présenté
stéphanie et le com et à la dernière
pièce dans le grand plan du retour à la
normale en 22 ans bientôt même le condom
se dit il va rester quelques poches de
résistance
on a vu des statistiques par tranches
d'âge et par région il y avait environ
10 combinaisons tranche d'âge région où
on avait des taux de moins de 50 % il
savoir rester mais si les enfants sont
vaccinés on a une couverture mur à mur
une des meilleures au monde et je
comprends ce que christian dit on aurait
besoin de plus de débats sans doute mais
là où il y as résistance à la
vaccination dans d'autres pays hollande
allemagne etc on voit que ça se passe
pas très bien non plus alors moi je me
disais qu'on soit là c'était sous cette
idéologie sanitaires pour avoir mes mots
de monsieur il faut stéphanie conclusion
la tuer moi je pense que tant mieux si
les gens sont parmi les plus vaccinée
ici au québec et puis je comprends qu'il
faut il faut pas y aller en braquant les
gens c'est pas la bonne façon d'arriver
à accroître la vaccination chez les
enfants est évidemment mais oui plus on
est vacciné et puis plus on peut revenir
à une vie normale rapidement et tout se
fait en sorte que oui au québec à
montréal on a eu un rebond économique
qui était important ce n'est pas à
négliger non plus parce que des gens qui
souffrent quand tu es quand l'économie
va mal qu'est ce que vous pensez on va
aller vite je devais tour de table
près de là dessus parce que je vous
parlais de nadeau dubois après qu'est ce
que vous pensez des libéraux qui disent
c'est impossible qu'ils étendent
exception médical chez les conservateurs
qui n'ont pas été vaccinés est-ce que la
bomba christian li zhi vous avez envie
de sauter bah je trouve ça bon exemple
de ce que je dénonce je trouve ça
terrible 6 ports sata ou sebha c'est
odieux c'est un contournement qui vient
d'être réélu là il revient en chambre
c'est tous ces dons qui on a parlé a
commencé à focaliser sur les députés
conservateurs qui seraient pas vaccinés
pendant un an il faudrait contre
vérifier les rapports des médecins je
trouve c'est l'exemple de où on est
rendu parce que c'est d'intérêt public
est ce que ça va augmenter la santé des
citoyens c'est tout ce qu'ils ont à
offrir sa malle lointain voix soit rendu
là sont alors allés son geste est odieux
ok on vous dit il n'y aurait peut-être
qu'avant un autre sujet pour commencer
la session alors écoutez c'est un
nouveau gouvernement si tous ces c'est
ça la priorité de taper sur les
conservateurs entendent ev des députés
qui sont pas vaccinés on veut avoir des
rapports des médecins parce qu'on est
rendu l'udc
les libéraux se sont fait plaisir en
tapant sont des conservateurs mais les
conservateurs ont entendu la joule
d'abord parce que des tous les employés
fédéraux ont eu l'obligation de
vaccination alors mais les élus leur est
pas ça tient pas debout et il fallait
qu'il fallait que les conservateurs
accepte de passer par là je pense compte
tenu du fait que ça a été imposé aux
employés fédéraux par ailleurs ils
étaient ravis conversant contre
lesquelles ils sont ils sont aussi
contre les céréales et des cibles date
n'est de la tatane de réduction de ges
oui changement climatique ça fait
beaucoup de choses contre lesquelles ils
sont dans une très petite période de
courtes périodes de temps d'ici à noël
et qui encourage
ses fans et 30 secondes là dessus mais
moi je suis d'accord on aura envie de
commencer à parler de notre change la
franchise que ce débat là mais
honnêtement je crois que les
conservateurs pourraient montrer
l'exemple et aller se faire vacciner je
comprends qu'il ya des contre
indications médicales
congrès de québec solidaire je recevais
le cochef le co porte parole futur s'ils
sont élus de ce qui a été désigné comme
étant celui qui allait être le premier
ministre sur nadeau dubois est ce qu'ils
n'ont pas assez d'après vous je commence
avec voulu que vous connaissez les
parties très militant avec des
propositions
qui vont très très très loin ont-ils
réussi à ramener québec solidaire un peu
plus vers le centre d'après vous
oui je dirai oui d'abord parce qu'ils
ont éliminé la question de la gratuité
scolaire de notre plateforme ils disent
qu'ils vont la peine en deux mandats
sur les jeux et les experts alors
proposé d'aller jusqu'à 65% des groupes
militants l'ont proposé les jusqu'à 65%
dans lesquels commis le temps il y à des
experts eux ont dit mais on en 55 %
comparé à la cac et à 37% ils ont voulu
se placer entre les deux îles sont des
tentatives ceci étant dit je doute de la
possibilité
d'arriver à un niveau 2
de fluidity qui leur permettrait
d'atteindre de pouvoir ils ont encore
très très très encadrés par leurs
militants ce qui est une bonne chose
pour un parti d'opposition c'est
particulier mais des idées c'est
particulier convictions mais pour un
parti qui veut prendre le pouvoir c'est
le plus difficile ça sur l'artère on est
un client
moi j'ai l'impression que celui qui a
été le plus déçu du congrès la fin de
semaine c'est gabriel nadeau dubois bon
je sais qu'il a dit autre chose
publiquement lors de l'entrevue qui
faisant accordé c'est ambitieux très
talentueux c'est le personnage politique
qui mentent je pense qui est assez
intelligent pour réaliser que québec
cellulaire
sus par s'il veut avoir de l'avenir il
faut qu'ils se ressentent donc en fin de
semaine on a constaté que la base est
fondamentalement radical et que ne
suivait pas gabriel nadeau dubois je
parlais et même je règle dans les
dossiers identitaire là-bas la base peut
être anti québécois lorsque lieu d'aider
bol sur la loi sur la laïcité les
accusations de racisme ont fusé et ils
refusaient d'envisager
un vrai problème pour gabriel nadeau
dubois
je pense que lui est consacrée devrait
se recentrer il ya comme un moment mais
le problème c'est que la base est
erratique à stéphanie oui c'est sûr que
c'est le test du réel la
quina du bois ça soit pas évident parce
que les si les militants disent bon ils
veulent aller jusqu'à 65% réduction des
gaz à effet de serre le monsieur nadeau
dubois réussit à amener sa 55% mais ça
demande bien au dessus de ce que la caq
rue pelée peut-être pas assez ambitieux
tout de même il faudrait qu'on retire
les routes et tous les véhicules à
essence qu'on enlève toutes les
émissions gaz infections de
l'agriculture comment voyez arriver en
huit ans c'est quand même c'est quand
même difficile à croire alors quand les
gens vont se rendre compte les électeurs
de ce que ça signifie quand on va mettre
des chiffres derrière les belles les
belles idées je pense que ça va faire un
peu mal stéphanie le christian merci
beaucoup bonne soirée à très bientôt
pour voir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit